and we are a lot yes
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the November charity
livestream we're here to make breakfast
for you I want to introduce Tyler hello
I want to introduce Ethan hello and I
want to introduce myself and everyone
who's in this room
Amy Evan and Catherine over there on
main control yeah whatever
what's the first time you've ever had
that kind of reaction no just look at
her she's yeah she's yeah she's she's
she's kind of a wild card that might
accidentally take down the whole street
yeah that's what I'm mostly concerned
about because there's a lot of wires
around here that we've got everywhere
and we could possibly have a hazard here
but more importantly than anything that
we've already talked about and we'll
talk about on the stream even the
children this is our bombing for
punishments holiday board so here we
have a number of very mysterious
punishments that we're gonna be enduring
mostly me because I'm a jerk but I'm
gonna be doing a lot of these
punishments and we have this lovely
bucket of apples and ice cold water
we'll be putting more ice in this water
as we go along
but every time we get punished or we
have to do a punishment which will
happen every $10,000 raised
we will someone not sure how I'm gonna
do rock paper scissors rock paper
scissor in it or is it like if we lose
the thing or look what we'll do that
without it but that is an island oh we
could Rock City Paper Scissors or we
could just cycle through so it could be
like oldest to youngest or vice versa I
don't like that your first to be
punished yeah that was your first
mistake
gosh alright so we're gonna be having a
lot of fun here but we are raising money
for Save the Children and our goal this
time is really really really high it's
two hundred thousand dollars which is
higher than we've ever had
before it's not higher than we've ever
raised before but it's the highest goal
we've had through pure monetary
donations so Tyler can tell you more
about this and we'll be talking about
throughout the stream certainly there
are a number of ways to contribute as
you can see on the till to five page we
actually have a lot more information
this time you can go to the schedule you
can see exactly what we're gonna be
doing every time we're live we're doing
a different activity there's gonna be
different punishments and during the
breaks we're gonna have a goal for the
next time that's gonna affect us in the
next time we are alive the other thing
there are incentives if you go to the
incentive page there are shirts they're
actually an older design that we had
left over and in storage for a few years
yeah
that and they're all organized by size
and all you have to do is donate 50
dollars and roughly forty three of those
dollars will go to the actual charity
itself in the long run because there is
some shipping costs to that and that's
the only thing that's getting taken out
is that shipping so if you go through
that be sure and pick the right size and
then the charity itself is Save the
Children I'm in the bottom corner I
think it's said that corner is at that
corner it's one of the corners there's a
package oh it's up here uh-huh
alright well it's up there on that
package is for every 50 dollars it will
fill completely up and you will watch it
as it fills up and every 50 dollars that
affects 4,000 babies that gives them
life-saving vaccines that gives them
medical supplies and medical check-ups
that they need as they that they develop
whether it says an infant or when they
are first born and Save the Children is
a huge big organization that reaches
over 120 countries including the US they
provide education they provide
life-saving medical treatment and they
definitely come into action during
crisis because children are the most at
risk when crisis occurs they protect
them from harm they do all kinds of
stuff all for children and families with
children and the reason today that we
are the goal is 200 thousand dollars
which is higher than we've ever had the
goal is because we have a very
very very very generous anonymous donor
that is willing to match the donations
up to two hundred thousand dollars so if
we hit that two hundred thousand dollar
goal that means we will raise a total of
four hundred thousand dollars for Save
the Children which will be awesome so
let's do it yeah
so everything you do is double this time
around everything that we have here is
going to be doubled so even the actions
that you take if you can make a donation
if you can share the stream if you can't
tell people about the tilta five-page if
you can go out and let people know about
the stream that's another possible
donator who whose donation is going to
be doubled during this stream so if you
can please let people know about that if
you can please let people know about the
stream about the event that we have
going on about the organization that
we're raising money for it will do an
incredible amount of good and we'll be
able to have some fun all day because
every ten thousand dollars that we raise
we will be doing another punishment and
overnight we already raised seven
thousand dollars for charity so look
down the description for tilt fi comm
slash at markiplier all the other
information there if you're on mobile
there's other ways to reach the donation
page just check around do whatever you
can and please help share it on Twitter
and Facebook wherever you can we'll come
up with a stream hashtag soon and let's
have some fun so this is the lot live
markiplier makes which means that we're
gonna be starting off this day with a
nutritious breakfast for all of us to
enjoy
so are you guys ready oh oh I'm so ready
ready Freddy it's already ready Betty
yeah Betty's ready for spaghetti okay so
here's how it's gonna work we're gonna
make a whole smorgasbord of breakfast
for you and that includes eggs bacon
pancakes that's not each of us gonna
make one we're going to each gonna all
make every one of those and then we're
gonna be judged on the consistency of
the eggs on the crispness of the bacon
and the accuracy of whatever pancake
we're gonna try to actually make sure I
say what sorry go ahead
no please continue it's sort of like a
sort of sort of like we have each thing
we have to make the pancakes we have to
make the bacon we have to make the eggs
but we can also say
use other ingredients that are in this
kitchen as well why would you do that
that's what we talked about Oh to spice
it up and make better eggs okay you know
maybe if you're a plain Jane does it
look like I'm a plain Jane you know I
know Oh mr. sternum what color is that
it's all right you know yeah you got it
on that one okay so we're gonna get
started here do we have a timer and we
forgot to get a clock oh we got a timer
oh we're actually on top of things this
time around yeah Oh phone now it's very
smart
they have timers and then okay yeah Wow
okay we talked about 15 to 20 minutes
last night with ten five five all right
okay all right ten i lineman is each 15
I'm what I just said ten okay I'm gonna
harden you who votes ten I got one vote
I'm voting NO there you having I don't I
don't like you anymore
I got we got enough votes here we're
gonna go 15 captain we need you Oh pass
but I failed not too late all right
countdown will start go oh I should
probably turn this on Abby I don't know
how to use it you must turn the Deuter
what degree I don't know okay everybody
just make sure be very careful with
these griddles all right you could
really burn yourself he's safe I opened
I didn't open the Baker open says me
anyway I'm gonna just take the relaxed
route
I like to start off my day with some
sweet delicious butter you get that
butter I gotta thank the bacon do we
want an amount could I have a butter
yeah the butter go get it the ceiling
why well that wasn't the ceiling I'm not
gonna lie that was all me that 100% you
yeah mmm you're the worst I know it oh
man one of the livestreams gonna get
smellivision are you smelling you smell
this you smell what The Rock's cooking
mmm smells
I'm going to use this table as a cutting
board oh is that maple bacon made it is
ah that's a good stuff you up yeah yeah
cuz we wanted to do uh we want to do a
market Blair Mixon we were gonna do like
a whole bunch of different things and
then we always just kept going back to
market makes pancakes and just like that
was a very very wholesome very lovely
way to start off the day and everyone
had a great time moving this stop
it's that timer stop alright who's being
party agree Tyler wait wait careful
careful careful careful careful careful
careful careful careful now hold it
yourself hold it yourself
on the other side back here on the hair
on the other side you're good don't walk
on your knees you're a bad knees what
does that mean you have to close your
eyes your eyes are open right now
close eyes
it doesn't matter close your eyes close
your eyes I don't think it closes eyes
you just spit so much or just right in
there use those t pers t for Sutherland
struggling so much it's 16 which is I
ship it
wait that punishes us yeah I ship it
which is where the other two players get
duct-taped together god damn it I made
all these punishments without the idea
that I would be the one being punished
that's damn it damn it
all right well butters that's gonna be
some berry lads karma for all right you
want to be back-to-back can we do side
to side why would we do that easier to
make breakfast oh here comes here comes
a B wait do I get to do it or do you get
to do it I mean I guess that's fair yeah
all right we got you you only get a
certain amount of time to do this okay
all right lift your arms up I'm gonna
give you use of your arm okay that's
fair what a gentleman I'll hold that for
you don't burn yourself
that's okay well all right all right Nev
oh it's burning hang on I've got a
situation here I need to share your
I've never made bacon before all right
820 oh no all right uh that's a splash
zone I'm turning that heat that I have
to get some eggs I'm sorry okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry thrown it come back to
Papa I don't want to just splatter
though all right that I've mastered the
one handed egg crack have you maybe okay
I'm gonna put those over there all right
I need an egg now oh I have an egg here
you want it no oh I have my own eggs all
right I've also mastered the one-handed
egg crack watch carefully
I caught some of that splash yeah
perfect
just like a chef no I need the pancake
thank you that's it hold on I'd like
some make sure that your hands are clean
before okay I'm gonna take this bowl
okay I need a cold water I know where to
get it I have to get some cold water
spinny spinny who shut your mouth you
don't know where his mouth has been I
know exactly where his mouth hasn't been
that's married he probably doesn't know
that pretty all right all right can I
get a turn of the griddle you greedy
person taking this
[Applause]
[Music]
very bad bad
nothing nothing nothing what's bad
nothing what's bad about anything that's
going on here nothing at all feel like
my feet turned up a bit why I don't know
just feel like it should mmm smells
delicious in it well I don't use my ass
to scratch here and so I'm just gonna
lay down the rules of the dump today I
need one more egg just you know just you
know you know oh boy uh-uh nope that's
what you call not working ah okay one
flip - flip red ship blue ship okay all
right Oh where'd my bowl oh all right
yeah my bacon is it working your bacon
is stupid and I hate it
Wow all right how about you calm down a
little bit stop using me using me beard
scratches hang on I don't know if this
ratio is correct but I'm gonna go for it
all right all right it's pretty good
this is good oh boy
this is not great I'm gonna do a little
flip of the bacon I've been feeling
there's gonna be a watery pancake iData
play hold on hold on Oh where's the
place I'll get you one to eat thank you
you're such a gentleman
no I'm not it's over though now I
thought that was a real boobies
you can have a turn mistake number one
what no no that was another playboy hang
on oh I hate getting so close to me hi
oh really we're getting close to you
Tyler wouldn't that just be I can't
imagine what that would be like I
literally what would happen in that
circumstance pilot watch your elbow oh
boy oh boy
I'm gonna borrow some pancake batter why
no mine's very watery you want to add
more bit of mix of that trust me
I need a bowl just have more than mine
oh you're lucky I have to wait for this
hold on back it up back it up back
in the wagon
how much Thanks oh it's good by the way
the donation link to the tilta 5 page is
down in the description below so if you
want to make a donation and get us out
of this contraption we have to get to
the next punishment before we do
anything I'm doing a little mix all
right okay you can mix not there you can
pick up thank yous all right now it's a
little all right all right all right
excuse me sir no no mm-hmm
sir in the middle of something sir no
nah I need you to move I need you to
shut up but that ain't gonna happen so
we just gotta live with things in life
all right go for it
turn that off there boy my eggs my eggs
let's try that out there beautiful oh
thank you
there we go all right now for the real
challenge see a good
mm oh that's too thick yep that's what I
was thinking as well biscuit biscuit Hey
all right you know I gotta flip this
shaman you you you can wait okay that's
fine i have to wait anyway good good
good good great great great great great
and flap okay anyway so yes the tilt the
file link is in the description below if
you guys want to go see that well
alright I was talking but donate yeah
save them from their current punishes
you donate over a certain amount you
will be shown at your name will be shown
at the top of the screen has anyone
donated what's the max donation right
now I don't know Jeepers Creepers broken
on the green even finish breakfast yeah
all right isn't that bad I mean based on
math we need to get it thanks thank you
we need to get twenty-five thousand each
time you're alive twenty-five thousand
dollars an hour well I don't know if we
need to impose such rules but that yeah
that's the average braid or which we
have to do this by well how long have we
been going for yeah what's the time know
much about old time of the stream Oh
nineteen minutes we've raised uh like
90,000 owes right let's down dollars a
minute that's pretty good pretty damn
crazy that's pretty darn good
no no no I'm plating the most delicate
portion of the exercise
can you stop rubbing yourself on me
that'd be great just can't resist I know
ah wait so are we alright you can go do
we are we eating these are so hot it's
hot it's so hot no it's good okay I'm
just touching hot driving with my hands
hot bacon thirty seconds I need a
garnish well or do we are
garnish hey golden brown what is this
cranberry orange relish good I love it
you love it we all love it who does both
cranberry pancakes
black okay all right okay like that was
not plated see I was not plated that was
not plated I went I laid it was coming
off the spatula no no that was not
plated judges okay that was not way I'll
accept that
Oh Ethan you know we're buddies what
what how is it all fair game bleeping
after the time of well in chopped I'm so
hungry
cuz this job in cutthroat kitchen if you
didn't plant it then it's not there gun
count right I don't know this what what
what did even not have plated and
nothing you have no right heads to
definitely leave it on the griddle maybe
eat it I probably should have left some
of this on the griddle for a little
longer anyway alright anyway we're done
here so judges good or rather judge all
right you are
you're wonderful thank you alright
anything you don't get a fork why I'll
get even if I'll even I'll get you I'm
getting cranberry everywhere you get
yourself a fork alright yeah these are
for you
yeah so and hold it up everyone to see
so this is what I called the hot cake
topper pressed directly over the bacon
and egg with the egg is seasoned to
perfection and the bacon is cooked crisp
seasoned up with what salt yeah good
alright we're gonna have it back
it's a little probably underdone the
pancake Bacon's really good good
consistency all right I call this
sunrise on a war-torn evening as
everyone knows when the red Sun rises
blood was spilled on that previous night
and so I don't know the yada yada yada
the pancake is cooked thoroughly the
eggs are cooked thoroughly and I use
butter and the bacon is nice and chewy
I prefer crispy bacon I do like the
chutney that is yes the orange cranberry
chutney really like oily see I'll never
get to see what your breakfast yeah
thank you thank you very much I
mentioned here's my lesser half I called
this Oh hold on I want to be faced this
way a little bit you know cheat out to
the audience I call this we decided on
15 minutes the previous night and then
it was changed last minute and then I
was duct-taped to a person enjoy pancake
guarantee yeah it's like yeah a little
too thick but it's not oh and there's
two types of eggs there's that one well
a try and Voltron bolt that's it oh yeah
good combo good combo a good egg it's
good okay how's the bacon Bacon's really
good would you say the best of the bunch
I would like to argue I just tasted my
egg it is not underdone it's just nice
and fluffy oh that's not you can't wear
your nan side yeah just because you like
raw eggs doesn't mean that the judge
does that is true there is a work of
this do you well you want a ring for
like my own ego I would love a winner if
it's not me then we don't need a winner
no we need a winner yeah well can you do
first place per thing yeah you didn't
get a punishment that's right yeah I
didn't have a hindrance yeah exactly
what's your Excuse I didn't turn my
griddle up high enough to cook it fast
Oh if you give me time to cook you want
to fight that well I think we've said in
the beginning of this thing you've never
cooked the bacon before so that doesn't
mean that I'm bad at it yes well how
hard is it to be bad at cooking bacon
exactly that's what boy all right all
right can we take the duct tape off so
we could enjoy our breakfast dishes yeah
well we got to do another punishment
wait what donation are we at well you
got to do another and then we'll decide
between the two of us which one goes all
right I'm going I'm going I'm going
unmuted and then just can't hold it I
think we can also mute it over there
all right all right make sure your eyes
are closed your eyes we're not very
close last time
the numbers that was straight-up just
biting you just wanted crack acquire to
be really there's no Apple there alright
good rings really good mark would you
like a piece of my bacon no okay I got
better bacon I just got it hey you want
to view this your top your top I'm
begging you you can do it we believe in
you I believe in you this breakfast is
pretty good you know give everyone
suction it suction it in just like give
it the good suck you can do this you
know you pay for entertainment oh hey
cadet afraid you're getting waxed yeah
yeah buddy
all right let's put these down like set
up over there
yeah what Zagat we can get out of this
now burst free like alien how hold on
push against each other just really like
really like no we got this okay gonna go
that way you go you go that way I go
this way okay all right this way right
okay all right one two three go
[Laughter]
my butter cutter ain't working ah my
bulbous hips it's caught all right fine
we give where's a knife give me a knife
there's a big old knife all right do you
trust me no oh great here we go they're
free all right so you getting waxed and
then we got another dog for you no huh
where do we gotta go well we all knew
you guys are but with the waxing kit all
right so while we get the waxing kit I
just wanted to say that was super fun
we've got more fun in store we're gonna
do punishments and then we're gonna
we're gonna clean this up and keep going
but we got to wax him and then we got to
do another punishment so if you guys
want to see more punishments please make
donations below we do them every 10,000
dollars and we will not skip any if we
have a debt to pay we will make sure
it's done we will get these punishments
out and we'll raise a ton of money for
this awesome charity and we're gonna be
talking more about it obviously they got
the extra strength if there's a debt to
pay we'll make sure it's Tyler hey you
all so much mace wax do you want the
face wax no oh do you have to microwave
this I think so I get get this get your
punishment in order all right we gotta
decide who's gonna get punished the bus
oh that's trial three depends on who
wins first no that's two another fee all
right and we're going to hop y'all shoot
okay right yeah yes
yeah yes yes yes yeah get go funny no
okay hold on 30 seconds on that why do I
fill up my water quick I don't know to
see you remove the other join him he's
gonna get punished and then I'm gonna do
Tyler for me please
no no I'm gonna mute just hold it away
any minute now
oh no oh yeah puts the tub this way oh
my god okay no Jake oh you want a Bob
for an apple just wait until you stick
your head in there you go Bob
this is tough to open I told you nobody
believed me why would we why would they
they don't even know they're assuming
this is super easy
I'm assuming it's super easy and I'm
standing right next to you so that say
something about you more than us you
shut your mouth about what that says
about me I'm the only one that knows
what says my man I'm gonna say that he
can't get an apple in his mouth come on
you gotta use it do you have to use the
side big dog
when I get bobbing in there I'm gonna
get it first tried my huge head this is
clicking large Riley Apple it's here I'm
gonna have to swallow it and extract it
later and that drive so you're saying
water just going to my mouth but don't
do that this is this is awful is quality
entertainment this is awful I'm not
looking forward to this wax are you
unmuted
I am unmuted okay cool boy oh it's
sticking to me how dare it well I mean
that's the whole point of what's already
pulling off my finger hair you how many
fingers do you possibly have well do it
harder then my teeth hey Haley twice
come on okay that that's the one the one
he's determined
I admire his determination three yay
three Shawshank Redemption it you get
the shock collar no no no that's so
stimulator
[Laughter]
Corinne in there it'll be fine that's
gonna be so disgusting by the end of
this all right
so I'm sitting pretty with no
punishments I have now I've been
punished once and I persevered through
it and I won the first competition and
the loser was Tyler Ethan just coasting
in the middle ground which is totally
fine I guess but this this charity
extreme is super important and it's
gonna be really really really difficult
to get to our goal we have a long way to
go we are just starting and we're doing
amazingly how much have we raised in
total actually I can see right here we
have raised almost $25,000 in just about
30 minutes which is outstanding
incredible thank you guys so much fast
as ever that is probably the fastest
we've ever been on trajectory but I
really do encourage like if we ever stop
this momentum all day we will not reach
our goal so if you haven't made it
if you were thinking about making a
donation do so through the link in the
description below
tilt defy calm at markiplier and you can
go there and you can see all the other
people that have made a donation this
goes straight to the charity we don't
make any money off of this none of us
make anything off of it so if you have
an opportunity to make a donation and
you can please please do it'll make a
world of difference and you can even see
like the names if you donate over what
is it over $20 well $20 your name
appears $50 feels feels that package
yeah and if anybody feels that pack I I
was hoping you were gonna go answer it
you were close Phil Phil's that package
up there so please please give if you
can give you've never given before if
you've given a thousand times before and
you can still give just a little bit
please do cuz today every donation is
doubled yeah we could raise $400,000
today in less than 24 hours we could
raise $400,000 for this amazing charity
that helps children's children all
around the world where are you guys
gonna lean he's good
oh we're gonna watch you over there okay
please give to this charity for the
backs this grown man please we're gonna
wash them for you
no we will wax this man also we have a
special surprise in store for anybody
that donates over a thousand dollars or
more which there are occasionally people
that are super generous and donate that
amount we have a very special surprise
to really celebrate those people to do
not saying like they're better than all
the small donations because those small
donations really do make the world a
difference but we just really want to
celebrate the generosity that comes out
in all these events and so we have a
special surprise waiting for you and
just thank you everybody so much please
take the time to do that it's time to
wax yeah under the directions you man
direction of the hair because that gets
maximum hair polite oh I know I know how
to where where are we wax in here you
want me to flip the bucket and sit in
the bucket oh yeah not gonna
you were talking about the Apple tub
yeah totally what's that older than that
all right okay
all right I think it's only fair I think
it's only fair only fair since both of
us got a punishment the first round we
each get a wax a leg I think technically
I got the punishment it just happened to
affect both of you but I think that's
fair I think that's fair though okay all
right okay all fair all fairness that
late you can choose an alarm if you so
choose okay do you want same leg both of
them
I like symmetry we're here to take care
of you I like symmetry you like symmetry
I like symmetry cool all right we're
gonna be as symmetrical as how hot is
this is this like lava hot it should be
okay okay let me know if this this burns
incredibly so top down like that who's
that you know it's funny you were like
let me know if this burns incredibly we
have ice water right there we could Oh
God all right hand it to Ethan then you
got to be careful because you don't want
to get we're scabs are and that's where
I keep hitting the side of my bed with
my shins crying a weak way no I go I try
and round the corner on my bed and I
just go what we do it I wasted all my
sense yeah yeah at the same time oh I
think I need to focus so I might have to
alternate it okay all right okay all
right you go with no you wax with you
pull against I think the directions are
in the box why I've waxed many times am
i right or am i right am i right
survival right I mean Empire
I'm gonna stabilize right here okay so
you get nice leverage all right don't
elbow me in the face I will no god this
is gonna hurt so bad you don't know that
I know that because we've done this
before yeah whatever
how long are you supposed to wait for it
as you shall do it it's it's like a
minute it's been about a minute are we
ready for me to scream like a little
girl
ready ready I'm ready three two one
aah oh that is a lover of pain hmm
I got a lot of the roots of that oh my
god nice this is your you're doing keep
oh my god it's so smooth all right nice
smooth you're welcome we can relax your
entire leg if you want yeah you want no
I've shaved my legs before I don't want
to wax my whole legs why why don't you
pit it a little bit just saw it a little
more than that yeah yeah
well I mean where are you going I'm
gonna go right on this if you gotta
don't don't please don't hit this get
right on there right in the scabs
we're just waxing they're scabs off yeah
you're scabs need to go there just
unsightly as oh no more picking your
scabs just waxing them jeez okay ready
and oh no going back now whew that you
were pushing down a lot harder and it's
making it burn oh you need another slip
of paper yeah you silly Billy you
thought that you could get away with
that
yes so I am putting more wax on but that
is to benefit you because if it's not
sticky enough then the wax won't come
off you know what it needs it's all
about pulling fast and you gotta be
hurry that's right you don't know doing
it well I know about it I'm trying to
help let him do it
I am this is my little bit of time off
there's no time this is the right stage
up yeah you give it a minute he's so
nice and keep rubbing it get your whole
hand on that ah yes ah really do they
like that muscle so if you want to see
more punishments we're already on route
to get another punishment under way all
right so we're already on the way to
another punishment and uh like oh yeah
you get muscle stimulator yeah but I
totally forgot about that one yeah okay
do it so then but we can have another
punishment after that and we can keep
going until we hit the next thing and
then we're gonna sign up for the next
event that we're gonna be doing you
didn't think about it no it was more
that was so much more hmm that was more
than that that's it because the skin
actually pulled out where you pulled it
this is like right against the bone oh
that's so sad for you I want you guys
just a plot just sign your name where
you wax off the hair okay sure maybe a
little weird better better tosses a
marker you've got better if you donate
now and your name appears on the top of
the screen if you or get your name on
there what okay okay he's gonna what who
are we good yeah now who's the first
person to come up
Sh ayyy okay I'm sure this is good for
Webb's skin
no not Sharpie not Sharpie why not not
sure because I'm a merman dear oh really
that has more time that's what was the
name thank you so much for your donation
you are incredibly generous and now
you'll be immortalize these will be
tattooed later beautiful calligraphy me
thank you okay time to put mustard
simmers can you go get the mussel
stimulators no noise there's some way
there's one right there but I'll get the
other one yeah so are we doing this
thank you so much for being with us here
we got a long way to go but once again I
will say we are raising money for Save
the Children and if you don't know about
Save the Children I've got some
information about it their goals are
very simple they hope that no child dies
from preventable causes they hope that
all children learn from a basic quality
and education and they hope that
violence against children is no longer
tolerated and you'd think those things
would be simple like everyone in the
world could agree to that but even in
the world that we live in today
like there's there's so many children
that need help because in 2016 alone
Save the Children helped more than 185
million children in 120 countries and
that's including the United States so it
may seem like this is a far-off problem
but even in our in in this country that
we live in right now even like first
world countries where things should be
civilized and people should expect
certain things like there's children
that suffer and don't have enough and
don't have the basic things and if we
don't protect our children then the
future generations that we have and we
don't we don't like instill in them like
hope and give them the tools that they
need for the future then I don't think
that like we will have a future because
we just need to remember that we are
here only to make sure that the next
generation is better off than we left it
so please help and donate to this cause
we have a thousand dollar donation from
wait wait
- whoa we got $2,000 donations want the
frizzies Andrew Babcock and the second
was Bjorn Johansson make sure there
weren't any more so and arukou Andrew
Babcock all right I'll take them no I'll
do it
all right sharpie on your chest all
right sharpie on my chest here we go
Andrew Babcock just donate $1,000 Oh
coppers are just Babcock just Bab that's
for you
that's for you how do you feel about
your new tat aren't you proud of what
you've done here aren't you so proud who
are the others now through your nude
yeah let's say they're gonna you I got
seal off the Babcock you
gonna make it like real like graffiti
like Ethan before he wrote on you no no
no we got on our go so just I got it I
got I got you know what I got this
[Applause]
[Music]
for you your good thing this is my job
oh okay my turn the bar you're trying to
Bob I'll Bob then you get that muscle
stem on on him don't forget I got don't
even you even come here don't even mute
me watch this first try I know how to
Bob perfect well I'm gonna do is forearm
you need to pick where you put it okay
starting on a low level right working
our way up yeah
as they donated get it higher so that's
the big thing about this one
this isn't that also unsafe no that's
what we're it's gradual there's no to
like start on oh yeah you have to ease
up yeah yeah did you would you get for
that's the normal ice bucket hahahaha
hey funny
what comes after you alright so normal
ice bucket is literally just a normal
ice bucket the what is this called I
forget what this is actually called
three dots there's a name of that the
umlaut oh no that the ellipsis the
ellipsis just makes it seem ominous
so normalize bucket so I'll do that
after we get this under where do you
like to put the second stack I've got
his ball you can't do that one each ball
we can do a leg we could do like I'm
screaming for balls
so I'm screaming for balls are you this
black boxes you could that's right balls
balls balls I've got a surplus of all
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right
I wanna make Bjorn dance okay no I'm
gonna make your pecs dance alright um if
you're gonna do that do his right side
so it's not over his heart that's boring
alright I'll make the ones death to
occur in the booth all right right uh
we're gonna put this on squeezers put
this one on the the sing softly do a
bull he's also having away he'll be very
stimulated hold on we have to decide
because we have we have the right to
decide when it goes like to remain by
violence
how many donation level oh no that's for
the other game absolutely laid her
that's for later what time we running at
that makes sense I don't like it but
sure we'll go with that one
I'm so worried that this I'm gonna turn
it on it and it's gonna be like 25 turn
it on mm-hmm I don't know Tyler do you
know how to use these sinner do you just
maybe you shouldn't hold I didn't do it
at the same time yeah you do it please
be safe though okay you're on channel
one adjust ooh tell me when it starts
twitching ah oh hey so we're going for
on that one oh wow that really hurts
that other one this one's or then oh
this one that hurts so bad oh wait what
was it what was what was that on I don't
know I couldn't tell which one it was
though it was
because I watched you twitch on this one
wait is this one on right now what is
this one gone for so you need to go to
the other channel and put it on water
okay
one wait oh wait Goggan toe Oh yep pain
oh you know you can put it up I just
like it
oh I'll stop stop stop down I think it's
this one yeah oh well this is a similar
grabby position so let me I'm sorry make
sure there we go both on zero
Wow well make sure it's really down
alright the other one - in any capacity
we have no idea what virgin okay all
right whoa up again one more okay super
flex in here oh my fingers we're gonna
try this again okay okay you okay all
right cool so ah we're gonna we're gonna
wrap this one up so this is me just
explaining how this is gonna work
we have eight events throughout the day
this is the first of eight we are going
to stop this stream we've got another
event scheduled up the next one is what
was the next one again
body art oh yeah it was beatable your
friends that's right ah so so in the
next one we have bloap which if you
don't know is a toy it's a toy that you
you both repent and it creates art it's
like spraying art it's like it's like
spray paint but blowing it with art so
we're gonna do body art with those and
we're gonna do body art we're gonna do
body art with those in the next one but
in the meantime in between each one you
can still make donations
we'll be back in just 30 minutes and in
those 30 minutes please take the time to
make a donation tell someone about the
next event its cued up and ready to go
if you don't get a notification about it
do ring the bell as much as a meme as
that sounds
hit that Bell you'll know exactly when
we go live and then you can tell people
about the donation page as well we'll be
back with more body art and then we have
six more events throughout the entirety
of the thing to go and if you reach the
next point of more punishments can occur
other than Mark Joseph we're gonna start
the next one with me getting ice bucket
'add which is gonna interfere with them
body yarding me but I maybe they'll dry
me off first
I'll find out final - yo so we'll see
you in the next one remember to share
that stream also give us ideas for what
the string hashtag should be on Twitter
and whatever else we can do how those
muscles Tim is doing well he didn't get
to do it through a whole activity yeah
all right so thank you everybody so much
we're not gone for the day so remember
the next event is coming up in just a in
just a bit so thank you everybody so
much for watching remember all the links
are in the description below this
charity for Save the Children we can
raise up to four hundred thousand
dollars just in this first section we
raised $35,000 keep that pace up we are
golden and and like if it comes down to
it I'm desperate there's so many things
that I'm willing to do to make sure this
goal gets hit that's right not a joke
why show up is what I'm gonna call this
mint pileup he will delete the Cheryl at
the end of the day no if we don't hit it
Oh so thank you everybody so much we'll
be back in 30 minutes right here on
marklar
and we'll see you in just a bit all
right thanks guys